eight months after he died the family of
detective Justin Terry is finally in a
wrongful death lawsuit good evening to
you I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise Valdez
the Metro detective was killed last June
when a metal beam in a construction zone
was hit by a tractor-trailer and that
forced it to fall on top of his car now
in the lawsuit the family names two
companies connected to that project and
the tractor trailer Sasha Loftus joining
us live across the studio tonight Sasha
has more Denise and Brian that lawsuit
filed today details what detective
Terry's family and their attorneys
called damages directly connected to his
death
it's right on top of where where the cut
where the driver would be it's been
eight months since detective Justin
Terry's tragic death
he was driving here on the us-95 near
Centennial Parkway last June when a
tractor-trailer hit a metal warning beam
in a construction zone that then hit
Terry's car killing him trust me I can
go on for hours telling you all how
great he was
but I will say that I cannot be more
thankful to have had him as a dad his
family speaking there at his funeral
filed a wrongful death lawsuit on
Thursday it claims Las Vegas Paving
Company the general contractor for the
Centennial bull project was quote
negligent in its placement and
Fabrication of the beam and didn't give
drivers enough warning it also names
Western States Contracting and the
driver of the tractor-trailer saying
neither fulfilled their duty to operate
in a safe manner by carrying an
oversized load exceeding its height
limit I will not miss anything more than
those big strong hugs that he gave when
I said
you later his wife and sons seeking
damages for their grief and sorrow over
Terry's loss in what their attorneys
call a quote 100 percent preventable
situation
now I reached out to both companies
named in this lawsuit tonight but did
not hear back in time for this newscast
detective Terry was with the Metro
Police Department for nearly 21 years